thì tại sao mà thế cho all đầu tiét mà tình ở sau để cho all đầu tiét.
Thế là vý dụng nếu như để bài này, người ta xửa lại không phải nhanh thêm ở sang của ta cho sấu tìm ở sang.
Vì bài toàn sẽ chở đừng câu chuyện hoàn toàn khác,
để giữa họ đã cao điểm, sấu tìm ở đây nghe xú đừng một lịch sấu nhật.
Thì nó bệ mì không để cho ông theo kiểu này được nữa.
Mà nó bệ mì người chia ở trên nợ,
tại vì cái sấu tìm ở sang thì bùi vai cho ông có thể nói, nó đồ khách nhau.
Mì không để cho ông bùi ở đây này được nữa.
Vì nó nắm thì ở sang nắm thì đó nó sẽ phang có thể nhé giao vào việc này đủ dừng.
Nên mình mấy câu cũng cũng cho một thè bất kỳ đập ở đây.
Và các cái trường ở bệ tẻ nào của nhé giao thì các cái trập ở nhé giao.